[Music]
good morning Hank it's Friday February
9th and it's laundry day you will note
that we have the world's smallest
washing machine it's the only washing
machine slash dryer that was ever
designed exclusively for Lua pew shion's
let's see how many clothes it will fit
one shirt one pair of boxers one pair of
pants two pairs of wait what's this oh
it's the naked in the dead in my pants
two socks one pair of boxers and it's
completely full
in fact it's kind of overstuffed I might
have to take out one of the socks Hank I
talked to Brotherhood 2.0 resident
mathematician Daniel Biss and it turns
out that there's a huge gaping flaw in
your mathematical theorem about old
people and dying and banjo concerts the
problem is this a 70 year old may live
on average to be 83 years old but that
doesn't mean that a 71 year old is just
as likely to die as an 82 year old in
fact the vast majority of people are
going to die closer to 82 than they are
to 71 if you want to see a person die at
a banjo concert the key is not to go to
banjo concerts that feature older people
the key is to go to longer banjo
concerts like 13 year long banjo
concerts Hank several brotherhood 2.0
commenters have been asking three
questions about my new book what's it
called when is it going to come out and
what's it about I am now happy to answer
all of those questions although I'm
going to answer one of them with a long
series of lies the book is called Paper
Towns it will be published in September
of 2008 it's about life in an orphanage
in Imperial Japan in the 17th century
it's about the world
origami championship of 2004 it's the
story of a special boy and his special
dog I don't want to ruin it for you but
the dog dies it's about an ambiguously
gendered child growing up in a Greek
American family it's about Hamlet it's a
historical novel in which I imagine the
teenage years of Emily Dickinson it's
about a face that is half in the dark
and half in the light it's about
learning to come to terms with the fact
that even though sometimes you eat the
exact number of points you're supposed
to eat you still don't get
less fat it's about how when the last
dingdong of Doom has claimed and faded
from the last rock hanging tideless in
the last red and dying evening that even
then there will still be one more sound
that of man's puny inexhaustible voice
still talking it's about a girl named
Becca who has a very happy birthday Hank
I'll be watching you on Monday from
lovely Washington DC see you then